l'autre jour je marchais sur la rue car
les sentiments cela en vibrer dans mais
dans ma fac
donc je me suis empressé d'aller
chercher à tâtons au fond de mon sac et
puis je me suis dit que ça allait mieux
à deux mains dont j'ai mis mon téléphone
dans mes poches
je me suis mis à chercher à demain au
moment où j'ai fait ça je me suis dit
que si mon téléphone tu es dans mes
mains que ça ne va pas être ce que j'ai
senti vibrer dans mon sac je n'ai encore
une fois d'aller signer mon téléphone
vibre et à main levée qui s'y est déjà à
lui signer son téléphone vibre et où ce
n'est tous ceux qui ont la main levée et
ceux qui ont pas osé le faire
premièrement pas de panique vous
souffrez pas d'une maladie grave et vous
n'êtes pas les seuls
définitivement pas les seuls une étude
récente a démontré que jusqu'à 89 % des
gens ont déjà ressenti un symptôme de
vibrations fantôme c'est tellement en
fait que le mot symptômes de vibrations
fantôme a été voté le mot de l'année en
2013 en australie mais qu'est ce qui se
passe dans notre cerveau qu'est ce que
notre téléphone fait pour le faire
halluciner des bruits et des vibrations
le phénomène c est relativement nouveau
au long centre ont sans doute donc que
peu d'études qui l'étudié non c'est deux
choses par exemple il ya deux facteurs
qui font qu'on en laissant tout d'abord
l'âge de la personne
plus une personne est jeune puis ya des
chances qu'on aurait centre deuxièmement
il y eu l'habitude de la personne
d'utiliser son téléphone pour réguler
ses émotions
c'est à dire qu'une personne que tu
laisses ton téléphone car elle est
stressée ennuyé au plus de chances d'en
ressentir
sachant que je suis jeune et 2 que
j'utilise mon téléphone pour réguler à
peu près tout dans ma vie pas juste mes
émotions s'explique bien pourquoi j'en
ressens souvent mais s'explique par une
autre phénomène par exemple des fois je
m'envoie des courriels à moi même pour
pour bien une information puis quand mon
téléphone vibre 15 secondes après je
m'empresse de sortie pour voir qu'est ce
que je viens de recevoir une somme que
ce pas normal
je le sais très bien ce que je viens de
recevoir six mois qu'ils appuient ce
bouton envoyer 15 secondes avant
pourtant chez incapable d'ignorer mon
téléphone qui est en train de vibrer
dans mes poches chez incapable de ne pas
répondre au téléphone
est-ce que je suis moins intelligent que
mon téléphone intelligent juste bête en
fait pas du tout la réponse à ce stade
battre mais bon ça c'est surtout je suis
conditionné le concernant est ce que
vous connaissez un peu ce que c'est yann
pavlov c'est probablement la personne
qui l'a le mieux expliqué il l'a
démontré en conditionnant son chien à
saliver au son d'une cloche
normalement quand sonne une cloche
un chien sas à l'export ça va retourner
regarder le son des cloches
mais quand président de la nourriture un
chien là il salive c'est un réflexe
si on veut conditionner un chien à
saliver au son d'une cloche ce qu'il
faut faire c'est qu'à chaque fois qu'on
sonne la cloche
on doit de la nourriture tout de suite
après progressivement la nourriture est
plus nécessaire
le chien vous salivez simplement en
entendant la plomberie de la cloche ce
qui est intéressant avec ça c'est que ça
c'est facile de remplacer le chien par
l'être humain la nourriture par un
message texte ou un compliment sur
facebook
et puis finalement la cloche par nos
téléphones intelligents qui sonne et qui
vibre un être humain en temps normal
s'est pas excité de recevoir d'entendre
une sonnerie de téléphone
mais par exemple un être humain
s'exciter de voir une vos compliments
sur une photo de profil sur facebook
si à chaque fois qu'on reçoit une
notification sont un téléphone on a une
gratification qui s'ensuit ce qui va se
passer c'est comme avec le chien
éventuellement la gratification est plus
nécessaire et on ressent de l'excitation
au simple bruit du téléphone il ya trois
facteurs qui font qu'on est conditionnée
plus facilement
tout d'abord il est le type de
stimulation est ce que c'est une
stimulation auditive visuelle ou
sensorielles ou encore mieux dans le
cône au téléphone
les trois en même temps le deuxième
facteur c'est la répétition
il faut que l'exercice soit répétée
plusieurs fois pour qu'on soit
conditionnée et finalement il ya le
délai entre la stimulation et la
récompense
plus le délai court plus là c'est plus
le conditionnement fonctionne bien
sachant que je suis définitivement
conditionnait répondent au téléphone
est ce que ça veut dire que je suis
dépendant pas mon téléphone cellulaire
comme ma mère me dit tout le temps en
fait pour tester ça je vous invite à
regarder nouveaux bains presque tout le
monde une boîte vide sauter là et mettez
votre propre téléphone dans la boîte
si vous n'avez pas de téléphones
intelligents garder la boîte ramener la
maison est donnée là votre pain ou à
votre mère
maintenant vous avez tout donné à me
donner votre lens pourrait maintenant ça
s'est fait peur que vous allez commencer
à m'écouter ce nom plus pauvres est
maintenant que c'est fait je peux vous
parler de ce que c'est que la dépendance
aux téléphones intelligents parce que
c'est une vraie chose on n'en parle pas
souvent d'ailleurs pas assez souvent la
dépendance aux téléphones intelligents
certains spécialistes appellent cela nos
maux phobies comme dans nos mobiles faut
bien où la peur de pas bord son
téléphone intelligent avec soi ça se
manifeste de différentes façons tout
d'abord par une utilisation répétée
obsessive et récurrente du téléphone la
personne va l'utiliser à tout bout de
champ jusqu'à ce qu'elles sont
au niveau des presque en lui tu laisses
pas ce niveau d'être et cela peut avoir
un impact dans la vie de tous les jours
dans sa vie sociale dans sa vie
personnelle et finalement même dans sa
vie professionnelle
donc si vous trouvez que vous utilisez
trop souvent vos téléphones intelligents
et que vous croyez que ça a un impact
sur votre vie il tente se poser des
questions c'est important de se poser
des questions parce que les téléphones
intelligents sont créés de façon à nous
rendre dépendants
je le sais de quoi je parle c'est mon
travail de faire ça tout ça parce que ça
utilise les mêmes systèmes de
récompenses que la drogue le sexe et la
nourriture
plein de belles choses de la vie hein le
système de récompense c'est la dopamine
l'ado la dopamine un neurotransmetteur
qui est libérée dans notre cerveau par
anticipation du plaisir
en temps normal on a une certaine
quantité de dopamine dans notre cerveau
après une stimulation ce qui se passe
c'est que le niveau de dopamine bord de
monter énormément ce qui va être
ressenti un peu comme un bien-être
après qu'on ait reçu la récompense le
niveau dopamine redescend la normale
comme pour signaler que tout va bien
donc encore dans le cas contraire si
après une stimulation la récompense ne
venait pas à l'arrivée
le niveau 2 promet une bonne chute est
énormément et ça va être ressenti comme
un mal être et la dopamine c'est très
très très puissant
saviez vous que l'anticipation du
plaisir c'est ce qui rend dépendants et
non pas le plaisir en tant que tel
c'est pour une raison de survie
l'instrument au besoin pour s'en sortir
dans la vie des méchas c'est d'aimer
trouver de la nourriture des métros et
des abris pour lui ses enfants
en fait des scientifiques ont voulu voir
si c'était vrai ayant pris des reins et
à l'intérieur de leur cerveau y ont
détruit les neurones qui libère de la
dopamine
après ce ils ont remis les roms dans la
cage et la plupart se laissait mourir de
faim pourtant il y avait de la
nourriture en abondance
il était physiquement parfaitement
capable d'aller chercher la nourriture
mais il ya l'étoile se laisser mourir de
faim parce qu'ils avaient pu la
motivation de son horaire donc la
dopamine c'est pas juste important si
nécessaire à la survie le problème c'est
quand les gratifications sont trop
rapprochés entre elles et surtout ça va
ça va faire que le niveau dopamine est
trop élevée dans le cerveau qui va avoir
une tolérance qui se crée il va donc
falloir encore plus de dopamine la fois
suivante pour ressentir le même niveau
de guénette
c'est ça qui fait la dépendance avec mon
téléphone intelligent on est toujours à
un clic de nouvelles récompenses
quand on est sur facebook on peut
toujours se rendre à des nouvelles
photos voir des nouveaux commentaires
le problème avec ça c'est que le nouveau
dopé mais ne jamais temps de revenir à
la normale je sais pas ça vous est déjà
arrivé d'être sur facebook pendant
plusieurs minutes 45 minutes une heure
et puis d'arrêter et de vous sentir
super fatigué après on se couche le soir
on sent coupable on sait pas pourquoi on
sent dans un état semi végétatif ça
c'est une boucle de dopamine peas et
c'est exactement ça se sentir des
pandores mais sachant qu'au téléphone
cdma china dépendance qu'est ce qui fait
qu'on n'est pas tous dépendants dans
cette salle c'est que pour être
dépendants il faut que le
conditionnement soit répétitif
heureusement pour nous c'est
complètement inacceptable de répondre au
téléphone
à chaque fois qu'ils sont ou qui vibre
c'est pas acceptable parce qu'il ya un
prix social à payer un peu comme la
drogue ça lincou monétaire mais le
téléphone un coût social d'utilisation
et de quel prix je parle
la prochaine fois que vos parents sont
en train d'avoir une discussion avec
vous au sujet de votre bulletin scolaire
interpellé pour répondre d'un message
texte de votre meilleur ami
vous allez voir c'est quoi le prépayé
c'est inacceptable parce qu'en plein
milieu d'une conversation je peux pas
m'arrêter prendre mon téléphone le
débloquer avec un mot de passe ou des
empreintes digitales me mettre à écrire
sur un clavier ça se fait pas ça
interrompt la personne à qui tu parles
avec les nouvelles technologies
intelligentes comme les montres par
exemple intelligente ou les lunettes
intelligente
le coût social d'utilisation est réduit
à sa plus simple expression
c'est sociable mans accepté socialement
accepté de regarder sa montre pendant
quelques uns nous parle du secrètement
ou encore avec une lunette et des jantes
sont encore pires la personne n'a même
pas conscience qu'on est en train de
lire un message texte pendant qu'elle
nous parle en diminuant le coût de
l'interaction à sa plus simple
expression
on s'assure une augmentation de
l'utilisation est potentiellement une
augmentation de la dépendance
est-ce que je en train de dire qu'il
faut pas utiliser ces technologies là
qu'il faut pas lui demander un cadeau de
noël pas du tout vraiment pas du tout en
fait moi même mon travail dépendent ces
nouvelles technologies qu'en plus ces
nouvelles technologies permet des choses
incroyables
ils permettent à des personnes qui ont
des handicaps de voir des couleurs ou
d'entendre des couleurs ils permettent
des découvertes technologiques qu'on
aurait cru impossible ya quelques années
et pour delà de toutes ces découvertes
magique on sait utilisation incroyable
il est tout les petits plaisirs qui
permettent
mes parents sont pas du genre à me dire
beaucoup quel sentiment éprouvez et
pourtant sur facebook quand j'annonce à
ma mère que j'allais venir faire une
présentation aujourd'hui à tedx un mot
écrit pour me dire qu'ils étaient fiers
de moi ou encore dernièrement mon frère
m'a appris que son fils avait fait sa
première france complète son fils c'est
mon neveu donc extrêmement fier de lui
et j'étais encore plus fier de lui quand
j'ai appris c'était quoi sa première
phrase complète je vais vous le partagez
avec avec vous aujourd'hui papa j'ai le
nez qui coule
donc en plus d'être extrêmement mignon
et d'être une très belle phrase complète
et parfaitement française
c'est beaucoup trop beau ces moments là
pour disparaître
heureusement il ya des solutions
il ya des solutions pour mieux utiliser
nos technologies portables
premièrement je vous ai donné une boîte
aujourd'hui qui dans la salle s'engage à
garder son téléphone dans la boîte
jusqu'à la fin de la journée au mal qui
s'y qui ont la main levée s'engage à
garder leur téléphone des démons du
monde qui ont même pas 120 x games qui
s'engage à garder le téléphone dans la
borne jusqu'à la fin de la semaine
ça veut pas dire dimanche ans ça veut
dire comme l'autre semaine d'après la
dernière fois que j'ai fait c'est avec
des adultes la personne qui la gardait
plus longtemps le garder pendant quatre
jours je vous mets au défi utiliser la
boîte ramener lâchez vous mettez la côté
de la table à manger et forcé tout le
monde de la famille à mettre son
téléphone dedans avant de manger tout le
monde la famille savait aussi des vos
parents
deuxièmement d'été définissez les règles
d'utilisation de votre téléphone vous
pouvez vous faire des règles à vous même
par exemple - mon copain c'est définitif
on n'a pas le droit d'utiliser nos
téléphones pendant qu'on est en train de
se parler ou deux en train de manger
troisièmement c'est une fonction qui
viennent sur vos téléphones qui
s'appelle ne pas déranger la plupart des
téléphones long et c'est important de la
m de l'activé le soir pour moi c'est
entre 9 heures le soir et 7h le matin
personne ne peut me rejoindre et les
gens savent même s'ils essaient je le
saurai pas qu'ils ont essayé mais par an
début j'avais peur que s'il ya une
urgence il puisse pas me rejoindre mais
j'ai mis leurs numéros dans le contact
d'urgence
c'est les seuls qui peuvent passer
quatrièmement refuser les notifications
des applications vous téléchargez je
sais de quoi je parle quand je vous dis
que ces notifications l'eau se sont
créés uniquement pour vous rendre accro
à l'application refuser les qui allaient
dans vos préférences pour refuser les
autres applications finalement
identifier votre nouveau dépendance si
vous croyez que votre utilisation des
téléphones cellulaires change la façon
vous interrogez que vous interagissez
avec les gens va pour le mieux que votre
niveau de dépendance est problématique
ou celui de vaud
frères et vos soeurs vos parents ou vos
amis il faut vraiment parler
parlez-en avec la psychologue de l'école
entre autres à va vraiment être capable
de vous diriger vers les bonnes
personnes finalement c'est vrai que les
technologies changent comment on
interagit en nous
pas toujours pour le mieux heureusement
il existe des solutions pour ça ils nous
ont peu changé la façon qu'on utilise
les technologies
aujourd'hui j'ai un souhait pour vous je
vous ai donné une boîte et laissez votre
téléphone celle là plus souvent dans la
boîte pour mieux en profiter quand vous
leur portez merci